Trascrizione: Adriana Centrone
Revisore: Piero Cavallo
Parliamo spesso di innovazione.
Innovare, dal latino “innovo, rinnovare”.
Ed è grazie alle innovazioni
che oggigiorno viviamo più a lungo,
salviamo più vite e salviamo più soldi.
In generale, possiamo dire
che le nuove tecnologie hanno portato
ad un miglioramento sostanziale
della qualità della nostra vita.
E sono infatti le nuove tecnologie
ad aver permesso il passaggio
dalle cure basi, o terapie tradizionali,
alle terapie innovative, terapie avanzate.
Fortunatamente ne abbiamo di diverse
e oggi ve ne descriverò una
in particolare:
l'ingegneria tissutale.
Chi di voi ha mai sentito parlare
di ingegneria tissutale?
È una disciplina in continua espansione.
Ma difatti, se guardiamo indietro
nella storia, nei primi anni del Novecento
un chirurgo statunitense,
che vinse anche il premio Nobel,
scrisse un libro intitolato:
“Coltivare organi”,
dove lui si domandava:
“È possibile coltivare organi?“
Beh, ne abbiamo fatta di strada
fin da allora
e oggi condividerò
i progressi di questa disciplina.
Partiamo dalla definizione
di ingegneria tissutale.
Come ci suggerisce
il termine “ingegneria”:
ingegnerizzare, costruire, creare.
Che cosa?
Tessuti od organi.
Dove? In laboratorio.
Si basa su tre principi:
biologia, chimica ed ingegneria.
Dalla biologia prendiamo le cellule.
Il nostro organismo è costituito
da 38 trilioni di cellule.
Le cellule interagiscono tra loro,
formano tessuti.
Più tessuti insieme formano gli organi
e gli organi costituiscono
il nostro organismo.
Poi, prendiamo la chimica
e dalla chimica prendiamo i materiali.
Nello specifico, nell’ingegneria tissutale
parliamo di biomateriali,
ossia materiali biocompatibili,
capaci di interagire con le nostre cellule
senza apportare modifiche,
senza dar vita a reazioni avverse.
E infine abbiamo l’ingegneria.
Dall’ingegneria prendiamo
le tecniche innovative,
le tecniche alternative.
Ad esempio, abbiamo la stampa 3D
che permette di mettere insieme cellule
e biomateriali
in un costrutto tridimensionale
che va a replicare un nostro tessuto
o un nostro organo.
Vi faccio un esempio:
abbiamo un paziente
che, a causa di un incidente,
ha perso massa muscolare.
Cosa possiamo fare con l'ingegneria
tissutale in questo caso?
Prendiamo dal muscolo
del nostro paziente le cellule.
Avremo cellule muscolari.
Le cellule,
aggiungiamo il biomateriale
e con la stampa 3D diamo vita
ad un costrutto tridimensionale
che replica il tessuto muscolare
del nostro paziente.
Questo tessuto è funzionale,
si può impiantare.
In quanto tempo?
Dieci giorni? Quindici giorni?
A fronte di anni
e una lunga lista d’attesa necessaria
prima di ottenere un trapianto d’organo.
Ma non è finita qui.
Cosa possiamo fare
con l’ingegneria tissutale ancora?
Allora, abbiamo in questo caso
un paziente,
paziente che soffre
di una patologia scheletrica,
una patologia di cui non si sa
ancora nulla, è una patologia sconosciuta.
Dal nostro paziente, dalle ossa,
recuperiamo le cellule ossee.
Le cellule ossee, le andiamo
ad aggiungere al biomateriale
che, in questo caso,
avrà una composizione chimica,
delle proprietà meccaniche, fisiche simili
al tessuto osseo del nostro paziente
e con la stampa 3D diamo vita
ad un costrutto tridimensionale
che replica il tessuto osseo
del nostro paziente.
Non possiamo impiantare
questo tessuto osseo,
è un tessuto che deriva
da cellule non sane,
è un tessuto patologico.
Cosa ce ne facciamo?
Beh, studiamo la base della patologia.
Riconosciamo di che patologia si tratta.
Identifichiamo marker utili
a scopo terapeutico
e individuiamo la terapia specifica
e mirata per il nostro paziente.
Mettiamo insieme: medicina rigenerativa
e medicina personalizzata.
Bello, no?
Fare ricerca in maniera non invasiva,
senza utilizzare
la sperimentazione animale
senza andar contro ai principi etici.
E tutto questo in pochissimo tempo.
Beh, questo è quello che ci auspichiamo
di fare con la nostra ricerca.
La missione di una ricerca sostenibile
e alla portata di tutti.
E l'ingegneria tissutale
può aiutarci in questo.
Ritornando, quindi, alla domanda
del nostro chirurgo statunitense:
possiamo coltivare organi?
Oggi possiamo rispondere di sì.